Good morning, Jaramillo comes out,
a massive fire is happening today in the valley
in a north recycling center,
the spikes and flames could be
seen from all parts of the city, the
incident occurred near
Ryan and Comerci streets, according to firefighters from
Nuevas Vigués.  some
recycling items outside the building
ignited but they have not yet determined
what was the exact cause of the fire and
long traffic delays for
drivers were reported Monday morning following
the closure of the southbound i-95 freeway
that was closed in
Harold's exit Police report that they were
forced to close that section of the
highway while a
man with a knife inside a
business in the area is being investigated. Until the time
this report was recorded, no new updates had been given
and in another  news that is still
developing today a child under 3 years old
was thrown from a balcony on the third
floor of a building after which the
police d  ice was an incident that
began with a shooting near power
highway and disorder on sunday
authorities found the injured minor
and a man with a gunshot wound that he
supposedly received from a member of
the minor's family so far the
minor is still hospitalized and is
The status of his condition is unknown as well as that
of the man
and attention fans of the
team riders Las Vegas' opens its first
game of the season at home and it is
anticipated that more than 60 thousand fans
will attend the stadium this is the first
game  of the season where the public will be able to
attend to enter the
game vaccinated fans must show
proof of their vaccination status
those
fully vaccinated will be able to attend without a
mask while
partially vaccinated people will be able to enter
but with a mask
parking lots will open at one o'clock
afternoon and the gates open at two the
game starts a quarter after
five  'Let's laugh now we'll pass with your
weather forecast a hot sunny day is expected
and with a view
today's maximum will be around 105 degrees the
temperatures will start to be close
to normal to end the week good
day I'm I left Jaramillo and this was  your
brief informative of insein in Spanish
[Music]